That's the happy sound of one
of my favourite molecules,
carbon dioxide, being released
from captivity inside a bottle
of sparkling water.
Now, the reason why sparkling
water tastes so fantastic is
because the carbon dioxide
actually dissolves, giving a
slightly acidic carbonic acid.
But what this carbon
dioxide look like?
Well, I have a little
bit of it here.
And we've cooled it down
so that it's a solid.
And it's a very interesting one,
because it goes from the
solid to the gas without passing
through the liquid.
So it actually sublimes.
On my left here, I have a big
tube of water which has a
little bit of indicator in it.
Watch what happens when
I drop a bit of carbon
dioxide into the water.
Of course, the carbon dioxide
starts to sublime immediately.
And it forms loads and
loads of bubbles.
But as those bubbles rise
through the liquid, a little
bit of the carbon dioxide
actually dissolves and
gradually the pH of the solution
begins to change.
And so the indicator
changes colour.
And you can see its now gone
from purple to blue.
And slowly it's changing
from blue to green.
And eventually, it will
become yellow.
What this is telling us is that
the water is becoming
more acidic.
Now, you might think that this
is just another pretty
demonstration.
It's not.
It's actually really serious.
As we put more and more carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere,
one of the things that is
happening is that the CO2 is
dissolving in the oceans.
And as that happens, the oceans
are becoming more and
more acidic.
And that really spells disaster
for all kinds of life
forms that can only live in
a very narrow range of pH.
And so while we have here a
beautiful demonstration, in
reality it's an alarm signal
for what we're
doing to our world.